recogen alambres y recolectan chatarra
estos sobrevivientes del terremoto
tienen el objetivo de revender lo que
encuentran entre los escombros para
poder subsistir
entonces el terremoto destruyó nuestra
casa ahora vivo en el mercado público de
marcha audi estoy buscando chatarra para
vender y darle dinero a mi madre para
que pueda cocinar y alimentarnos
los residentes llegan a los sitios de
recolección allí por los cables que
cortaron extrajeron pueden ganar unos
cuantos dólares las recicladoras por su
parte están más ocupadas que nunca
después del terremoto encontramos la
mercancía en abundancia
el terremoto que dejó más de 2200
personas muertas también destruyó 53 mil
viviendas y dañó otras 30.000 por lo que
ver personas buscando sus pertenencias
básicas en lo que quedó de ellas es una
escena común en diferentes regiones del
país en maniche así lo hace el psoe un
joven futbolista que se adentra en lo
que alguna vez fue la casa de su abuela
maniche en una casa de dos pisos que fue
destruida ahora estoy buscando cosas que
necesito como el pasaporte mi partida de
nacimiento algo de dinero y mi ropa se
come
a la crisis de infraestructura se le
suma la crítica situación alimentaria
por la pérdida de gran parte de las
cosechas y los asaltos a la ayuda
humanitaria pasan los días y no hay
soluciones claras para asegurar las
necesidades básicas en haití un país que
sigue sin un liderazgo político firme
desde el asesinato de su presidente el 7
de junio